hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm going to
be in Europe I would like to have some
meetups if any of you are interested and
available I'm going to be in France and
the UK essentially going by memory here
going from memory i'm going to be in leo
from the 11th to the 15th and i'm going
to put this in the description solely on
from the 11th to the 15th of december
i'm going to be in a town the name of
which I can't remember in southern wales
from the 15 to the 18th them so then I
going to be in bath which is in western
England from the 18th to the 21st and
then from the 21st of December to the
second of January I'm going to be with
my son and his family in London they
live in Wimbledon and then from january
third to seventh i'm going to be in
Paris so if we can find some common
dates there where people are interested
and available i know it's the holiday
season so it's probably not so
convenient but just on the odd chance
that there are some of you who want to
meet up i'm certainly available so
please let me know and that's it I've
got some ideas of videos in the new year
I do the issues I want to attack one is
this whole issue of and I get it all the
time people see yeah I'd love to learn a
language but you have a talent that I
don't so that is a myth of and dispel
and the other one is people say you know
add link I don't want to convert my the
blue words the unknown words to known or
even two yellow because I'm afraid I
haven't yet learned them i have to learn
them don't worry about learning words
forget the words relearn them forget
them again relearn them again that's the
fastest way that you're going to acquire
the words anyway there'll be more on
that in the new year meantime let me
know if you're available for a meet up
and check the list on the description
here bye for now